Rồi trước của bà thằng địch không hề tiếp xúc với Mỹ để bản về vệnh cảnh bênages về la sẽ ra sau
Nếu tổng thống Nicolas mà đúng không còn tại vì
Đồng thời gó gắt thông tin bảo truy đưa ra trước đó là phí li và sai sự thật
Cú thề thứ trường ngoài rao dô sau vì nào vì đang
Nó ở với hãng thức tấn à phê rằng
La hà bà nâng chưa tưởng cho độ về Washington về bất kỳ vẫn đến lỗi bộ nàng của bênages về la
Và cáo buộc một số nong dù chế nó bị đã dự trẻ
Nằm chế dễ hành động lãng dì hận theo đường lối sau chủ biếp của bà bà bênages jaelà
Tông thời nhằm tạo cơ cho các hành động cân giản hơn của Washington trong khu vực
Tên bộ của cú bà được đưa ra đúng lúc Mỹ đầy mạnh chuyến dịch tấn công các tổ bị nghi
Bồn bản mặt biếp ở kai bề bà thái bình dương
Cúc như đầy mạnh điều động khi tài
Chính dức này đã khiến hàng trục người th mạng và làm quan hệ giữa Washington bà cá các thêm càng thẳng
Nói ra Mỹ cũng cáo buộc ông Maduro
Cương lợi từ hạt động bộ bà mặt biếp
Còn cú bà nó mới đang tìm các gây xức áp để làm xí ổ đồng mên của họ
Bộ nơi giang Mỹ bóng bộ cá cá bộ cho rằng cú bà và bệnh nơi dây la gây bất ổn khu vực
Và hành định chế dịch trống mà tuy mạnh tài của tổn thủ đưa ra trăm
Nhằm bảo vệ an ninh trong Mỹ, chuyến dân cú bà cho biết họ vẫn vý trì hợp tác trong cún bà mặt biếp với tổn dân Mỹ
Và uống tiên chia sẻ thông tin là hà bà nàn nhìn mạnh không có cuộc tiếp súc đi mất nào với Washington
Và gọi cá tìt trên truyền thông là nỗ lực giào giả nức dựa hành nước là phía hình cân